let's talk about what you did all right
so for those that aren't familiar mr uh
lobliner right i'm pronouncing it right
low blinders good liner you're tim you
call me whatever you'd like to see i
screwed it up so you you have we have
these this box of uh uh what do you call
it it's a whole food bar right yeah it's
the uh it's a whole food protein bar
it's called the outright bar sitting
right behind you yes and you announced
just i think it was not even two weeks
ago yeah that you were pulling out of
kroger supermarkets because of their
their coveted policies yes um
and that was a decision that i woke up
and i read the news
and i'm like you know what i just can't
sit back
and be complacent look i am not anti-v
word not i'm not at all my kids all have
them i have them but under this
circumstance and situation some people
might not be able to get these
i mean i believe lydia you can't get
yeah they told me not to i i was told
i'm not supposed to get it by my doctor
so they're saying that we're gonna
penalize you for not getting this
and there's no one fighting for the
employees
these guys are alone no one's fighting
for them you got biden's administration
saying that if companies don't do this
they're killing grandma and they're
complicit and whatever you're losing
money on this i'm losing money yes can
you say how much money or do you want to
keep that private seven figures
million millions of dollars kroger is
huge they're huge they own other things
like ralph's like it's a segue into the
other door wow we're in the final steps
of the conversations and i was like i
woke up in the morning and i ran it by
my wife now you guys don't know me as
well as my wife knows me rightfully so
but i have
i kind of have the tendency to do things
a little rash a little brash you know a
little bit spur of the moment like i
don't think things through so i actually
did and i'm like katie what should i do
she's like this is the right decision
because
for me it hits hard it hits home because
being complicit when
you have this kind of tyranny and this
kind of fascism take over
that's what led to world war ii oh mark
you can't compare this to nazis yes i
can
yes i can it's the same path and by the
way i lost my entire family
to nazis in world war ii the only reason
i'm here is because my grandfather
escaped auschwitz and because
people like me who own businesses people
who can influence people to do the right
thing they stood by and just said oh
we'll be okay let me just take care of
my family today oh i could pay my bills
today i'm fine oh i got money in the
bank i'm fine until the government comes
confiscates and puts you on a train and
that's what happens and if we don't
stand up to government overreach like
this my goal with this was to get other
companies to follow but they have no
spines and they are greedy bastards
bravo
absolutely give me another hour i have a
lot more to say
oh we got we got an hour and a half oh
cool uh so so sitting behind uh just
right right behind um mark is his
outright bars
which uh they're delicious yeah we we
have a bunch they're amazing and it's
like peanut butter honey and all that
good stuff protein yes whole food
protein bar yeah you did the right thing
man you you wrote a letter to kroger
saying we cannot in good conscience
support this but it's not just about
what governments are doing about what
these businesses are doing
you stood up to kroger you stand to lose
a lot of money by doing it yes and there
are so many people who are like i won't
take that risk like you said i'll just
take care of my family and
what you end up with is
one step at a time things get worse the
more people are willing to tolerate the
more the the the evil pushes and
encroaches until finally someone says
enough i'm not going to stand for this
look tim me going on an airplane and
refusing to wear a mask and getting
arrested nobody cares it's not going to
make a change
what i want to do is make a change from
this level and hopefully other companies
follow and that's where i'm that's where
i'm at with this it's like okay i'm one
product out of thousands and thousands
of products at kroger they don't care
they can live without the outright bar
you know what and you know i'm gonna be
just fine i'm gonna pay my bills i'm
gonna be just fine my kids are gonna be
fine
but if i didn't make this stand who's
going to lead the way who's going to be
the first one to say hey
i'm not putting up with this anymore
i'm not going to stand by
and watch them abuse their employees and
i'm not going to stand by and watch the
government overreach on people's
freedoms and rights like we talked about
earlier it's not about whether the
medical procedure is safe or not it's
about freedom
it's about choice and i'm not going to
stand by in the greatest country the
greatest country that ever existed in
the history of this planet and let these
bastards destroy it i'm not going to do
it not on my watch i saw a viral video
of this nurse or one claiming to be a
nurse saying they fired her for not
getting vaccinated and then they called
her up they sent her a text saying can
you come back and work because we're
desperate it's like well consequences
man they brought back kyrie irving yeah
because the vaccinated players got sick
with coving and he's the unvaccinated
nurses are irrelevant kyrie irving is
the big loss to society right that guy
dude not only does he have tremendous
game but his shoes are really nice nice
huge fan of the kyries
but what you were saying about kroger it
was it was a very important moment
because they took a step further than a
lot of other corporations out there they
decided to say we have a whole bunch of
people working for us helping make this
cut this company
they put their blood sweat and tears
into it and we're going to set a policy
that takes away their benefits away from
them if they don't take a medical
procedure that we want them to take
which is absolutely crazy it's
mind-boggling and the people working for
for krogers should be thinking twice
about who they're working for when they
have management like that and there was
a lot of protest against kroger there's
there's also a lot of people saying
kroger wants to move into florida a lot
of people were organizing a lot of
different efforts to say hey we're not
going to support this business we're
going to vote with our dollar you took
it to another level which i think is
commendable because you absolutely put
you know your blood your sweat your
tears on the line for for freedom we i
talk about this all the time about how
people are unwilling to sacrifice to do
what's right you did exactly that and
and then some i mean look man
seven figures in sales you could buy
yourself something real nice and fancy
but instead you said freedom's more
important so you you know you bought you
spent a lot of money but you bought
freedom place a little bit well my what
example look i have three kids i have a
soon to be 16 year old girl a 13 year
old boy and another 8 year old boy
what example am i sending to my children
if i don't take a stand what example am
i setting to my children if i don't put
principle over profit
what example does that set for the kids
that i coach at a high school level what
world do you leave behind we leave
behind a really crappy world that
resembles countries that have never made
it america is the last standing beacon
of freedom we need to keep it that way
and it starts look i'm an idiot i'm a
meathead okay i get it i get all the
jokes i see all the comments on twitter
i know what you guys think about me okay
at the end of the day if an idiot like
me
can do his part and if you agree with
look if you agree if you don't agree
with me by all means don't don't
sacrifice anything but if you agree that
what's going on now is the wrong thing
you need to
local effect
can have a global change
you need to affect
local that's what you need to do do your
part i'm not saying do something stupid
and get arrested but i know there's
something that all of us can do
to help change i'll tell you this
one thing you can do for those that are
watching is if there is if you have a
kroger or well they own ralph's and
other stores
if you don't like the policies they're
implementing do not shop there i don't i
go to publix i the kroger is the coolest
publix was really good weren't they i
love kroger i do i always went there and
that's why this hurts so bad also our
our company tigerfitness.com and
outright bar were headquartered in
loveland ohio which is cincinnati
basically and that's where they're
located so i actually had you know there
were some of my colleagues who were not
too happy with this decision because
it's a local company but this is about
more than just cincinnati this is about
the world the best the best layup we
ever had on our sponsor ad reads was
when michael malus was on the show and
i'm like we do this shout out for you
know our various sponsors and michael
just interjects he was like guys these
companies that are sponsoring shows like
this are the companies you need to be
supporting because they're putting
themselves on the line we know how
cancer culture works we know that people
come after companies are kind of getting
kicked out of stores or canceled off you
know certain shows they threaten
advertisers
you need to support the businesses that
are actually putting something on the
line to defend these values yeah so
you you're walking away from a fat
paycheck and there's a lot of people it
kind of bums me out but look i should
put it this way
we should be er we should be standing on
uh on the side of optimism for what
you've done with your company and the
things you're saying it can be
discouraging sometimes like where's
everybody else
where where are the other businesses
that
have values that are have products in
kroger are going to be like we're going
to follow suit we're going to do the
same thing because i'll tell you this
salvation army
they got called out recently because
they had some critical race theory stuff
on their website
how fast did they backpedal and
apologize when donors started canceling
saying i will not fund this if people
start saying if you're a good company
that does the right thing i want to be i
want to help encourage your growth the
funny thing is the left says the exact
same thing and the right isn't playing
the game the left will be like guys
everyone go and support these companies
that are that are engaging in practices
that support our values support these
companies and they do it they organize
they get collective and the rights like
eh i don't really care i'll go to kroger
and buy one no no it's it's time to
start voting with your dollars and
voting with your feet and saying i'm not
going to support companies that are
sacrificing us and people need to
understand like like voting with your
with your money voting with your dollars
voting what your time what your
attention with your voice absolutely
matters to such a huge degree that if it
didn't that all hulk would have been
lost but there's been so many different
effects there's been so many different
people standing up for the right thing
and there's been a huge suppression of
it and mark i i think you know you stand
by these basic ideas you know
this basic idea of fame and money is
worthless in life especially at the end
of life compared to of course your
values the life you lived what you stood
up for and the world you left for your
children i think that is a lot more
important and at the end of the day even
though you lost out on some money i
think you made the right decision and i
think people will support you and i
think energetically synchronistically
things are going to go your way a lot
more because of people standing up
against people getting discriminated
against because let's just say you know
linda was working at kroger he almost
said lydia i know i know i had to
correct myself there we have an ongoing
inside joke here that's another story
but but like if you were working there
right you would have had your benefits
taken away right before the holiday
season you would have been denied basic
access basic help to survive in this
world because of your own personal
medical decisions that your doctor says
you can't take so that's absolutely
insane and crazy and then that deserves
to be protested minimally uh
at least with your dollars for just for
this segment people are wondering where
they can pick up uh
so the easiest place is tigerfitness.com
we're also available at every single
vitamin shop locally if you have a
grocery store hyvee
heb we're available at awesome local
retailers natural body in new york we
got everybody nutrition in huntington
beach we have over we have tens of
thousands of gas stations that carry our
bars um we're out there we're out there
and you know at the end of the day we're
doing this for the employees of kroger
believe it or not it might seem like
it's hurting their company we're trying
to change policy we're trying to make it
so they have no choice
but to say hey we made an error and then
talks resume immediately they resume
immediately i just want them to realize
their errors and this is not a good
thing this is not about this is pro
freedom this is absolutely pro freedom
and also one more thing when you're
talking about what what the benefit is
when i die and one day i will die okay
my no one's going to remember me for the
car i drove no one's going to remember
me for the house i owned or the
companies i had to remember for what i
did and the actions i took they're going
to remember me for coaching at a high
school level on my own time for free you
remember me the kids are going to memory
hey that's the guy who taught me how to
deadlift correctly that's the guy who
helped me win a state title they don't
give a crap that i did five million
dollars a year in kroger nobody's going
to care and my kids they're going to be
just fine but they're not going to care
either because they talk about their dad
and to talk about what kind of person i
was not how much money i made one of the
things i that really i've always
complained about people not standing up
for themselves i remember when i was
younger i had friends friends who were
servers at restaurants and they'd be
like we need to vote you know this way
or that way because they need to raise
the minimum wage it's not fair we only
get paid three bucks an hour or whatever
and i was like why don't you quit you
know my friends are back well i need the
job and i'm like do all of your
co-workers agree with you that you're
not paid enough that the the base rate
for a server is too low and they're like
yes and i'm like so you mean to tell me
that each and every one of you could
just be like hey we're all going to quit
unless like you could strike and they're
like oh i don't know about that i'm like
yo if you were all for this you need to
just say it the problem is they all feel
that everyone else is a coward
this person working there is like well i
would but then i get fired because no
one else will and i'm like well then you
work with cowards and if if all of you
if everyone working there just said
i don't want to work in these conditions
your wages would skyrocket overnight and
the cost of food might go up there's
repercussions here but you know
if people are unwilling to take that
stand because no one else will then we
we are in a downward trajectory if you
take the stand or if anyone takes the
stand you may be the only one standing
that may be the case but at least you
voted exactly how you needed to vote
that's what i tell people
i don't vote for party i don't care i
don't like the two-party system show me
something worth voting for donald trump
last year he did 2016. he didn't in 2020
i saw things i liked it i want to vote
for that i really do
and i don't like voting against people
i'd rather vote for a libertarian
candidate or uh depending on nowadays
maybe not a green party candidate but
i'd rather vote third party because i
vote for what i believe in
because if you vote for what you believe
in you've never wasted your vote but
everybody is scared they're scared of
the other they're scared if i vote for
this guy then this guy's going to win
well then we we all lose is that what
we're going to do no i'm not about that
so i got a lot of respect for what you
did by standing up and putting your own
company in the line putting putting your
bottom line on the line because some
things are more important very yeah it's
no question it was the right choice no
question at all thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 p.m and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website
where we are unrestricted in what we
talk about so you'll definitely not want
to miss it thanks for hanging out we'll
see you all next time
you